in which a 15 year old school boy has
been murdered
three had his whole life ahead of him
this was a premeditated and targeted act
of violence by two teenagers who wound
themselves with knives
the day that Kyrie should have got home
from school ended in the most tragic of
circumstances
both defendants tried to hide their
identities they were balaclavas after
they ran from this senseless attack
to change their clothes to avoid
protection
and it should have got home that day but
instead his family his friends and his
loved ones now face the future without
him
the bags that contain clothing were
hidden in Woodland later collected and
disposed of by others due to a
meticulous investigation by West
Yorkshire police the defendants were
identified as being the murderers
and due to the hard work of the
prosecution team and the crown
prosecution service we were able to
present a compelling and overwhelming
case at court
today these teenagers have been jailed
and start lengthy sentences
we hope that these convictions and the
sentences handed down by the court today
will act as a deterrent to those who
carry knives with a view to harm others
the message is clear
you will be caught you will be
investigated and you will be prosecuted
my sympathies and those of the entire
Crown prosecution service are with
Kyrie's family and friends today thank
you
okay thank you if ever a case
demonstrated the true horror of knife
crime and the culture among our
communities of people carrying knives
than the murder of Kyrie McLean was
clearly that
Cairo was targeted in what was a planned
attack on him as he walked home from
school
and as you've heard he was subject to a
vicious attack
we received unsurvivable injuries
today two youths
have been sentenced appropriately for
their involvement in the murder of Kyrie
I know today's sentences won't bring him
back to his family but again I do hope
that they provide some closure to them
and enable to them them to move on with
their lives thank you
Constable at least with them
and Charlie
afternoon
sure
good afternoon
on Wednesday the 21st of September 2022
my life changed forever
the coward's responsible for Carrie's
murder took the life of a son a brother
and a friend
Carrie was looking forward to a bright
future and had his whole life ahead of
him
he was a loving caring person who loved
Manchester United and loved rugby league
he was happy in a relationship and had
plans to study to become an engineer
all that was taken by two individuals
who brutally attacked him
Gary had no chance to run or defend
himself he was left helpless
quite soon after the attack I was told
Carrie had been injured so I went to the
roadside where he was
I had to watch helplessly as paramedics
attempted to save his life
no parent should have to see that
I would like to thank West Yorkshire
police for their support given to my
family throughout this horrific time and
for their quick arrest of those
responsible
I also want to pay tribute to the school
children and teachers who waited with
Kyrie and tried to help him
I now ask myself what has this achieved
what has my son died for
nobody has one in this situation I have
lost a child and other parents have lost
two children who have been who committed
this offense and are now in prison
this violence has to stop carrying
weapons especially knives has to stop
thank you